reject nation I am very excited you know
why this is Erik Estrada by the way
Cheers
Erik's joining me today to talk about
some veggie games and I decided cuz this
is one of the ones I have actually
played it's a big day
going out stressed we started with Devil
May Cry we're going out strong with
Resident Evil 2 the remake trailer which
actually Resident Evil 2 remake for
Gamecube which I liked Gamecube nobody
else I missed one in this game cube man
there's games on there that I still want
to go back and get yeah man Luigi's
Mansion
Luigi's Mansion isn't underrate I wish
there was a part two
nightfall was a double yes a [ __ ] and
they remade like not only do they remake
Resident Evil and then do Resident Evil
zero but they also remade the first
Metal Gear Solid yeah that's right Twin
Snakes yeah which is a badass game -
yeah so you know hey my GameCube is
right over there let's get into this
video there you go once I figure out
where they're Jackson the TV are it's
bolted to the wall how much mobility but
yeah we're gonna check out the trailer
for Resident Evil 2 remade I am super
excited I don't need to expound on that
anymore you ready - yeah what's up to it
here we go come for children games are
all about sugar
hey ketchup yeah that's very nicely
Toshi to catch it I appreciate that
yeah is this a playable rat if there's
not a rat playing I'm gonna be very
sorry if you beat the game five times
you get that pizza yeah
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
nurnies and don't make my mistake if you
see one of those things uniform or not
you do not hesitate never takes to save
this city I surprised you made it this
time
[Music]
[Music]
will you help me of course
[Music]
suppressive display owns drinks but we
never meant for this to happen
[Music]
it's coming back not bad just around the
corner was that out I think that was
like a brief little tyrant flash at the
end there well I'm sold on that yeah
that looks badass I think I think I
definitely give it a shot cuz you're not
the biggest Resident Evil fan no I mean
I think I respect the franchise as a
whole you know especially part six yeah
I think for me it was always the game
fluid mechanics the stiffness although I
understand that's what makes it a
survival horror game yeah did you get
into part four at all when they like
changed everything and did the
over-the-shoulder yeah I don't think I
played it but I watched my friend play
Resident Evil 4 and beat it and it's a
great game you know it's a great game
it's a great story and all that stuff
seeing this from what I understand
they're doing the same thing you know
they're changing the gameplay mechanics
a little bit I think they're even giving
you the option to go between cinematic
yeah and what they're updating version
half but no it looks great the graphics
look killer
I love the facial motion capture work
yeah I'm curious to know if they read
out the voiceovers mmm just use the
original audio at least with that one
little moment between him and the other
copper easily you don't hesitate yeah
really bad sounded pretty new that was
really fresh and again just leading with
that movie vibe I don't know if that's
gonna figure into the game at all I mean
that might just be like a cutscene or
something but I did like the rat POV
yeah and take a night cuz you know the
outbreak comes from the umbrella corpore
whatever but rats always have that
munich Abul disease kind of scourge and
to start the trailer from that
perspective I thought was pretty cool
yeah again I really loved when they
rebooted the first one back on GameCube
and this looks like an even crazier
version of that yeah I'm sure they're
gonna be adding some great yeah and they
big they cropped that Bob on Leon
Kennedy his hair always changes a little
kinda looks like benbarnes and now I'm
wondering just you know are they gonna
show like an origin story of where he
got his fuzzy bomber jacket
because he's in the police get up right
now yeah that's what prequels are for
right
boots are finding out where do you get
fuzzy bomber jackets this is a super
cinematic again games are very much like
movies but Resident Evil always had a
cinematic quality to it that's right now
in the free and the foreground coming
back to part two you know cuz part two
is a pretty big game in its own right
when it first dropped so yeah it makes
sense I wonder if they're gonna at least
do like a one two three sort of thing
and remake nemesis after this yeah
definitely why not you know I mean these
are definitely beloved franchises and
[ __ ] I'm still waiting for a Metal Gear
Solid 1 or that of course all three
remake yeah I mean that would be the
dream so I mean it's cool to see these
something because these are obviously
titles that we love and it's cool to be
able to relive that yeah special moment
all over again on an updated platform
this is the one place where remakes are
actually alright yeah yeah where you
don't have to worry there are a lot of
movies where you're like I don't know if
the extra tech really help video games
you're like no it did I think they've
got really good of water I've noticed
across all these games like water water
even the most important thing now and I
mean just that look at the zombies too
cuz they're a lot of zombie games and I
feel like Resident Evil still even in
this age of like hyper real looking
videogames yeah they still have a kind
of design that looks their own yeah and
I think that's because they add more of
a creature aspect yeah it's not just the
undead it's more of this like
abomination you need genes and all this
stuff so well that's another thing I'm
excited about for this game too is to
see how much a key or all those bio
creations are and I think the lighting
is gonna be a huge thing about you know
like the dark is gonna be much darker
now yeah and that's the other thing is
cuz this trailer again super cinematic
and so you have all these shots are
beautifully lit and freaky looking and
now I'm wondering what the actual
gameplay renders of those are gonna look
like and how the mechanics are gonna
function that way cuz as much as I like
some of the earlier Resident Evil games
with the locked cinematic camera it can
be kind of cumbersome at times not every
angle is the greatest yet yeah and some
things do get confusing but I don't know
I'm super jacked about this what do you
guys think are you excited
place a bottle of ketchup hit us up in
the comments below you like zombies you
like the undead will we're gonna end it
we're gonna watch some undead right now
you're not the biggest survival horror
fan not quite but I do have a couple of
games that I really enjoy I played a
demo and I had fun that one I play with
my friends which was very enjoyable okay
and it was really hard which was
refreshing well I've played a little bit
of dying light part one and that was a
scary experience cuz my friend had a
projector and it was really big you know
that's the way to play that yeah but
this is dying like - I don't know
anything about this release except that
I'm sure there will be more zombies so
alright let's hop to it
[Applause]
[Music]
you're great at heart good come on all
right - I think there's a function yes
reacts on multiple levels the things you
do and the choices you make in the
example we're about to show you my
protagonist undertakes a mission for the
peacekeepers one of the many factions
active in the city they want you to
negotiate with two survivors who are
control and hoarding a water supply
let's say you choose to carry out the
peacekeepers orders one way or another
after this you'll start seeing a
significant change in the cities as
access to the water supplies allow the
peacekeepers diverse stability and
develop the air
there's even running water for the
people at street level
and that raises the morale and allows
you to replenish your energy on the go
but there's a cost to this
the PK's of our rigid approach to law
and order
so while the streets may be safer it's
only safe for those who side with
if you get on the bad side
now let's return to that I have another
choice and instead of killing them you
choose to team up with this group to
supply water to our market Asya will see
this creates a very different set of
consequences for the city with water
being a precious currency it brings you
access to new resources and trade
but this in turn attracts the worst type
of people to the area and this is just a
single decision one out of hundreds
you'll have to make
but it allows you to carve out your own
world their own city for the apocalypse
each player's game experience will be
unique and by the way this is just what
happens in the day I played Resident
Evil 7 in VR and that was and that last
moment there reminded me a lot of that
experience I'm glad that this was not a
few oh yeah dude Oh Tecton
I think Tecmo same people I did so there
you go perfect I chose this specifically
because I knew that I was like tech land
of course I knew it my second favorite
game development I love the choice
options you know yeah definitely adds
extra dynamic to a game of course I
think that's one of my favorite parts of
the way games have grown over the years
and like all your choices because it
adds replay value yeah which is so
important you know there's nothing I
blowed more than buying a great game but
once I finish it I'm like you don't want
to beat it five more times flawlessly so
you can wear a tuxedo at the end instead
yeah all gold no it looks it looks great
it looks like it takes place in some
European country yes for something I'm
sort of English so that's cool because
it gives you an extra level of
environmental dynamics you know oh yeah
architecture to explore that one giant
panorama shot I really love that whole
you know jumping into a pad and sliding
down with the knife I - yeah it makes
the environment more alive yeah exactly
it makes it really feel like a real
place and the stop sign the know he
thinks I like everything
makeshift and it seems like civilization
starting to try to rebuild it so it
looks like this game takes place a
little bit further yeah in the future
from the first events out of all the
trailers I've seen so far this III that
was one of the coolest hooks for me is
like you start out with a couple of
violent zombie images but then most of
the focus of this is how you're gonna
interact with the human you know and I
love the dialogue options that's always
a sell point for me in any game really
you know choice a dynamic and bluish
story you know you get to create it yeah
so it's really great if anything this
makes me want to go buy the complete
edition of the first one you know yeah
so I think I'm definitely gonna burn
through that and pick this one up as
soon as that's ready just jump right
just jump right in there yeah I got a
buy one of these future consoles and I
think this is the game that may have
just sold me I'm doing that well what do
you guys think are you excited to relive
the Walking Dead because that's is the
other thing is that I also thought about
that too I was like oh we're gonna spend
a lot of time trying to make this human
thing work yeah and then zombies which
is not just the walking dead but it's
just the easiest touchstone right now
anyway what did you guys think of this
trailer are you excited to live in the
apocalypse and slide down billboards let
us know in the comments below and as
always you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get updated every time a review or a
video is out maybe I don't know or just
check back on the page that's the
easiest way come hit us up on patreon
thank you Eric for joining me any time
give Eric some love in the comments he's
not gonna look at them I told him you
don't wanna do that
I'll send either good one piece people